voici le courrier que l'intersyndicale
des artisans taxis de la martinique a
déposé le 28 décembre dernier à la
septième à l'attention du président de
l'exécutif
les taxis de place souhaite que la
dérogation leur permettant d'utiliser
les voies de circulation du tcsp soit
prorogé elle avait été accordée jusqu'au
31 décembre pour le tronçon allant de
l'aéroport au giratoire des dix lots
nous on a une dérogation de trader de
pouvoir accéder aux couleurs du tcsp 7
des vocations été respectivement nommés
par les autres parce que pendant que
nous on avait les l'habilitation de le
faire beaucoup des transports se faisait
dans le tcsp
on peut largement travaillé et cotisé
puisque le ccsp rumeurs ne gêne pas je
tiens à vous signaler aussi que par
rapport à cette histoire de tcsp
on a perdu pratiquement 70% du chiffre
d'affaires est la preuve de leur médecin
c'est une voie que nous servons
seulement quand il ya embouteillage très
difficile sinon ce n'est pas une voie
que nous passons devant toute la journée
pour le bon plaisir parce que nous
n'avons pas intérêt à passer dedans
quand ça sonne bien
nous allons plus vite en faisant
l'auteur dans sa cellule bien plus
qu'une simple prolongation renouvelables
les artisans taxis soit obtenir un
document définitif
c'était bien et c'est pour voir comment
ça fonctionnait maintenant l'essai après
fait il faut tirer les conclusions
maintenant moi à mon avis je vois pas
d'inconvénient parce que ça s'est très
bien passé il n'y a pas eu bien entendu
de problèmes particuliers comme je le
dis et donc la cohabitation en toi le
tcsp des taxis de place depuis monsieur
faire comme ça se fait d'ailleurs la
doua en attente d'une réponse de
martinique transports et du président de
l'exécutif de la cité m les taxis
continueront à emprunter les voies du
tcsp
comme beaucoup le font sans autorisation